[Applause]
what it is welcome back it's time for
the fastest first up you can't be in
Nashville and not talk about the queen
of country music herself Dolly Parton
someone popped the question to Dolly
someone's getting married nope about
whether artificial intelligence could
ever replicate her unique singing style
and here's what she had to say quote I
hope nobody can ever replicate me or
what I do AI is a scary thing Dana since
this is literally your second town and
you are a a music icon in terms of
listening do you agree with her I mean
who could ever disagree with Dolly she
is definitely America's sweetheart and
she's I think right especially when it
comes to creative people and creators
because they already saw their world
upended with streaming right and then
the industry took a long time to figure
that out I'm sure there's probably
people in this room that were part of
that and now you have things like
illustrators for example being usurped
and how are they going to protect their
own products and get paid for what they
do but the other thing Dolly says in
there is she talks about the
preciousness of and the uniqueness of
individuals and how important that is
and that robots could never replace us
Jesse let me hit you with a scenario hit
me all right so well some of this is
true you're on two number one shows
right Jesse Waters is a internationally
known man and CNN can't find a way to
beat you so they create AI Waters and
you're going one-on-one with the AI
Waters is this okay well I know my
greatest weakness hair narcissism
yes so I think I'd be able to beat
myself but you there will never be
another Jesse Waters and or or a Tyrus
or anybody because every human has
emotion and someday you wake up and
you're angry and some days you wake up
and you're invigorated and those that
volatility emotionally allows you to
create and have those highs and lows and
able to express yourself in a way that a
computer will never be able to do Tyrus
do you agree do you think do you think
about the narcissism if we created a
left leaning AI Waters no could he beat
the real Waters logically it's her time
Waters I logically yeah I I think it's
pretty easy for the left leaning folks
out there can AI Waters still interrupt
would he have blondee hair would you
have blonde hair
him like no he's perfect as he
is um that's really sweet said it in
public um the thing that I love about
Dolly Parton and the way that she talks
about these issues she always feels like
she's looking after who's coming next
next and it's not about her like she's
got she's done it all right she never
wants to be out there taking you
know credit for things she just silently
goes around doing good and inspiring
people all her work with the libraries
um and I Lov that about how she was
discussing this issue that clearly not
preserving herself but just saying
whoever's coming up next is going to be
up against this machine judge from a
legal aspect could Jesse Sue I I AI
Jesse true um honestly yes I think and
that's what the future is going to be
because what if you can if you can
finally identify who is creating the AI
and that's where I think that the
problem's going to be the Genesis of the
AI you absolutely can because they're
using your likeness and I mean there's
even in in many states that law it's a
civil rights law in New York which
protects your likelihood and people
using your likelihood for to make money
for themselves when you're not getting
any payment for it and as a lawyer for
Jesse I mean he Fortune for that kind of
thing thank you coun yeah no problem I
I'll send you my bill later though but
here but here's the thing that Dolly
Parton is she is right that she doesn't
like this because she is as everyone has
already said an icon and she got to
where she was she worked very hard
nobody gave her a helping hand she
climbed up that ladder herself so her
emotions her reactions her instincts are
different from what AI may think and I
would be and and I understand why she
would be insulted that someone would try
to do an AI of her so and I respect that
always imitated but never duplicated a
that's it I want to Brian kill me I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now